en ligne avec nicolas vidal directeur de
la publication de putsch médias bonjour
à vous merci d'être avec nous alors
votre réaction suite à cette nomination
de jean castex en qui remplacera edouard
philippe qu'elle est comment est ce que
vous avez à juger ce que c'était attendu
alors tu extrêmement intéressant
radiations et jean castex parce qu'en
fait pour moins bien plus premier
ministre en france il en reste
finalement que le titre parce que mes
manuels macron il vient de nommer tout
simplement tout bonnement un super
directeur de cabinet vous le savez vous
l'avez dit un havre de sujets avec des
hauts fonctionnaires énarques et ça m
finalement quelque part le bras droit
technocratique des maliennes vaincrons
finalement emmanuel macron qu'est ce
qu'il a fait aujourd'hui il a changé
l'identité du shaq de caen qui assurera
la gestion de la banque de france qui
est posé sur les pelouses de bruxelles
voilà pour ma première analyse cette
situation qui est extrêmement
intéressante pour cette nomination alors
comme pompidou giscard d'estaing
emmanuel macron a choisi de nommer un
quasi inconnu quelle est la stratégie du
président avec cette nomination mais en
fait c'est de détruire les obstacles
il avait d'abord philippe hourdain suka
udb tenir chez leur fille dans sa
réforme des retraites
emmanuel macron maintenant il a le champ
libre je lui ai dit c'est un super
directeur de cabinet donc on n'a pas
l'impression que jean castex va faire de
l'ombre à emmanuel macron mais bien au
contraire il va y laisser le champ libre
pour imposer sa politique on le sait la
politique néolibérale regarder notamment
la fois répondre des retraites emmanuel
macron a été claire mais là il ne la
broche sera pas la réforme de
l'assurance chômage de qui donc moi je
pense vraiment que c'est une nomination
ne s'évalue pas politique puisque c'est
une technocrate jean castex
donc on est vraiment aujourd'hui vous
saviez que nicolas sarkozy avait appelé
françois clients sur une liste de
collaborateurs
et bien non et de la meilleure
expression du collaborateur c'est un peu
l'identité la start up nation ou un
collaborateur qui fait passer les ordres
aux salariés aux stages rma viable pour
mettre en place une politique mais là on
n'est pas bien entre en prison vers la
france et ça pose vraiment plusieurs
questions ces deux nominations très
sincèrement alors avec un directeur d'un
cabinet du
nouveau premier ministre classé à gauche
en l'occurrence au nicolas réveille quel
message allez marion veut-il faire
passer selon vous une nouvelle fois je
pense qu'il n'a pas le droit de gage
écoutez je suis au contraire depuis ce
matin on essaie de lui expliquer que si
la gauche gaulliste plus qu'une série
d'adjectifs moi je crois que c'est fini
tout ça aujourd'hui il ya un projet
magna quoi un projet je le dis souvent
sous vos antennes un projet néolibéral
un projet tourné vers bruxelles on
rappellera la grande interview qu'il a
donnée la pqr hier emmanuel macron il
apparaît le souveraineté européenne sous
marins des français a totalement disparu
du discours mais ça ça fait un petit
moment déjà
donc non je continue à penser que honda
allait la france a marché au clairon et
aux sabots sabre au clair pour continuer
cette politique d'austérité pour
utilisation
vous savez sous les fourches caudines
union européenne ce libre échangisme
mondialisation et janquin carte ex
pardon et quant aux habitants une
technocrate haut fonctionnaire qui sera
le plus à même finalement de faire
passer les ordres à la majorité
présidentielle et à la politique
économique dans son ensemble
alors concernant ce bilan un d'edouard
philippe qu'est ce que vous retenez
surtout qu'il est montée dans les
sondages pendant l'épidémie est ce qu'il
ya là un futur candidat pour 2022 selon
vous et surtout sous quelle étiquette
alors dans un premier temps vous avez
dormi qu'il a pris la poudre
d'escampette au havre bien entendu il
est allé se relocaliser au havre pour le
coup est ce qui représente candidat
sérieux pour 2022 moi très sincèrement
je veux donner mon analyse mona jeu j'ai
plus l'impression qu'à une gauche et une
droite très bien établi aujourd'hui en
france ya le camp des progressistes
libre échangiste dans la mondialisation
et puis vous avez le camp des
souverainistes aujourd'hui cette
accélération des manuels macron qui
finalement est en train de déclencher la
machine à austérité à pauvreté avec jean
castex
on va voir où ça va mener la france
concrètement vous avez vu qu'à une
certaine émulation dévouement
souverainiste produits en france avec
toute une série d'initiatives
donc c'est seulement deux ans c'est très
très long mais ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui jean castex c'est qu'il ya
manuellement en place edouard philippe
il enlevait un obstacle donc son captain
finalement emmanuel macron l'a pris pour
s'entourer de ses personnalités
serviable des mangues fidèle et loyal
pour pour honorer son mandat mme brooks
est loin parce que c'est la seule
janvier quoi sont possibles et ses
nominations elle est extrêmement
importante et criant de
qu'est ce que la politique d' emmanuel
baron et pour edouard philippe bombay il
a fait son temps il ya eu des obstacles
ya eu des bisbilles entre eux d'ailleurs
apparemment son confrère jörg guinée
très agitée en début d'été a ajouté un
peu de replis pierre-emmanuel un
concurent et peut-être précipité la
démission du gouvernement
donc là pour en revenir vraiment au fond
du problème peut-être des missions de
chanteix elle est extrêmement
extrêmement importante elle et je vais
le dire elle est lourde de sens pour
l'accélération des manuels marquant dans
sa politique néolibérale
mais ce nouveau visage est ce que c'est
une manière d'apporter un nouveau
souffle à ce gouvernement qui a traversé
la tempête
bienvenue elle m'apprend est allé
piocher dans le mien le marigot des
technocrates
donc effectivement il va y avoir un
continuum de sa politique
donc là on venait toujours une part
philippe était un fonctionnaire jean
castex d'ailleurs fonctionnaires alors
oui effectivement c'est dithyrambique
d'ailleurs on apprendra que nicolas
sarkozy adore jean castex parce que
finalement sa meilleure qualité c'est
d'être servile ci d'être fidèle donc
d'appliquer le programme donc
d'appliquer les directives
donc vous imaginez bien que c'est
forcément extrêmement intéressant et en
plus c'est un peu d'huile de coude jean
castex parce qu'il connaît bien les
administrations donc si à un moment
donné il faut arriver avec un peu
d'huile dans le moteur
un jean castex sera le meilleur élément
pour pouvoir que la machine fonctionne
mieux fonctionné surtout plus vite
fonctionne beaucoup plus vite et
peut-être mettre au pas certaines
administrations qui serait rétive aux
réfractaires à certaines réformes et je
pense qu'elles sont nombreuses des
réformes alors un remaniement ça
signifie inévitablement un changement de
cap à quoi faut-il s'attendre en termes
de politiques notamment concernant à la
réforme des retraites et plusieurs
nouvelles reforme réformer et notamment
aussi cette relance économique
qu'attendent les français
on a lu tout ça c'est que cette
interview la pqr qui a été d'ailleurs
relu par les services de l'elysée
il y aura pas de changement de cap
assure avant le fond il ya une politique
de fond qui est là et il n'y a pas
raison pour emmanuel macron d'aller à
langon cette politique on parle
d'écologie on parle de politique sociale
en réalité vous l'avez dit mona la
réforme des retraites
il le dit très clairement mais ne sera
pas du tout la journée on va continuer y
aura des ajustements vous avez comparé
d'ajustement et de discussions
généralement je crois très peu mais eux
n'ont encore aucun n'y aura aucun
changement de cap réforme il m'apprend
restera sur les mêmes canaux
néo libéraux qui sont en train de mettre
à mal très mal la france et on aura
encore des manifestations bien entendu
parce qu'on aura de plus en plus de gens
qui seront dans la rue
donc non c'est un remaniement
nécessairement aujourd'hui j'ai eu là
dessus sur le remaniement des ministres
on s'en moque un peu du roman
d'humanisme puisque la pierre angulaire
du système il ya emmanuel macron et jean
castex donc finalement on se fout un peu
de qui va être ministre aujourd'hui
parce que la politique ne changera pas
d'un iota
à moins qu'ils nomment philippe de
villiers ou nicolas dupont aignan
l'intérieur mais j'y crois pas c'est
sincèrement donc pour moi il n'y aura
aucun changement de politique mais il va
y avoir une accélération de la politique
rappelez-vous qui a amené gagne 2 ans et
demi de lutte sociale féroce et qui
devrait prendre de l'ampleur dans les
jours semaines et mois à venir
alors justement ce conseil des ministres
il a été annulé
quelles sont les prochaines étapes de ce
remaniement quand est ce qu'on aura les
noms de tous ce nouveau gouvernement
mais là on va prendre un petit carnet on
va prendre un petit stylo et on va
essayer de poser des noms on a déjà vu
pas mal de choses
voilà on ne sait pas trop qui va être
qu'il va être nommé ci en a qui vont
rester en place
on imagine peut-être que le poste
ministériel aux critiques christophe
castaner va être remis en cause
peut-être le poste aussi de six bêtes
ndiaye porte parolat du gouvernement
mais aujourd'hui une nouvelle fois que
je faisais mon âge je crois très
sincèrement en termes de en termes de
changement on n'aura pas beaucoup de
changements dans la philosophie pour ce
qui est sûr ce qui est sûr par contre
c'est qu'on aura des gens qui sont
extrêmement fidèle loyaux et serviable à
emmanuel baron pour continuer sa
politique
donc il faut pas s'attendre à un
remaniement il pour finir là-dessus je
pensais que ça serait une connectique
estivale du cosmétique pardon estivale
ce selon l'omi nation part du premier
ministre
mais cette affaire où jean castex c'est
extrêmement intéressant et voir un peu
effrayant tout de même pour ceux qui
seraient contre la politique générale
emmanuelle bach rond nikolaisen vous
restez avec nous on va aller voir les
les récrés réaction pardon à de
l'opposition suite à cette démission est
la démission et d'edouard philippe qui a
suscité de nombreuses réactions à droite
comme à gauche écouter ils peuvent
entièrement changé l'équipe
gouvernementale féminiser davantage
mettre des trouvailles baroque et cetera
mais puisque ils maintiennent la même
politique inégalitaire et
anti-écologique
et veulent l'aggraver les mêmes causes
produiront les mêmes effets je tiens à
remercier edouard philippe pour tout le
travail qu'il a pu accomplir comme
premier ministre et je lui souhaite un
bon retour dans la ville qui lui est si
cher edouard philippe démissionne pour
un havre de paix vu ce qui va arriver on
comprend pour l'instant les futurs
prétendants font peur schiappa taubira
belloubet s'il s'agit pour emmanuel
macron de nous dégoter un premier
ministre qui met en oeuvre la même
politique libérale et valide la réforme
des retraites contre laquelle les
français se sont battus pendant des mois
c'est pas la peine de faire ton de bruit
un faux suspense et sur le changement de
casting qui n'aura aucune incidence avec
la poursuite d'une politique anti écolo
et sociales dépeçage de l'ambition de la
convention citoyenne réforme des
retraites
ce remaniement fait du prince symbole
d'une vème république à bout de souffle
fier des 1100 45 jours d'edouard
philippe à matignon et merci à emmanuel
macron de lui avoir fait confiance
vous l'avez entendu des réactions
différentes à gauche comme à droite on
l'a dit jean castex un personnage de
droite est ce que ça va affaiblir ou
renforcer le gouvernement selon vous
fait bien renforcé fait ça va renforcer
manuel macron là dessus mais c'est
extrêmement intéressant pour une info
j'ai eu quelques personnels personne vu
des républicains la semaine dernière
suite au remaniement et on se mettait en
ordre de bataille chez les républicains
de façon individuelle le précise pour
essayer de rentrer d'arriver à
grappiller un poste au sein de ce nouvel
gouvernement vous voyez bien que
l'espèce de quoi édition entre la règle
les républicains des gens où il n'y a
pas finalement entraîne d'idéologie il
n'y a pas l'épaisseur de papier à
cigarette entre les deux donc on va
continuer cette politique d'ailleurs
l'équipe et cf le dise même si moi je
n'ai aucune carte et pca m canalys
politique je trouve que cette nomination
jean castex
elle va oui elle va renforcer elle va
elle va va renforcer la politique des
manuels macron dans le sens où renforcer
dire qu'elle va les libérer totalement
le champ politique
des prises de décisions pour les
prochains mois danse extrêmement
intéressant parce que emmanuel macron
c'est une nomination extrêmement
stratégique c'est extrêmement
stratégique c'est compris de pouvoirs
constitutionnels des vents tendu mais
c'est une prise de pouvoir qui il va
falloir thème regarder la terre
jeune et je suis pas persuadé
aujourd'hui que ça va pouvoir il va y
avoir une sorte d'union nationale autour
de ceux de ce jean castex
merci nicolas vidal pour toutes à ces
précisions je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur de la publication de putsch
médias